in the last few years technology has
changed the way we pursue and share
information how we pursue friendships
how we relate to one another how
societies work and how information is
disseminated with any advent and
technology any technological innovation
there's the good and the bad the good a
somewhat level playing field where the
broke guy with an internet connection
can go to a cyber cafe and for a few
bucks no a whole lot of stuff real fast
no library needed get a lot of
information read local and international
newspapers etc etc the down part is
internet predators who have done awful
things to people who don't know how to
protect themselves
fraud and scandal where people have been
built out of all kinds of money
amelioration of privacy the fact that I
can see you you can also see me you know
there's that two-way and so that's a
downside but the ability to make a quick
contribution to a politician who you
feel some empathy with I think this is a
good thing the dissemination of
information on a just click gone like a
Twitter feed I think this is fantastic
I'm actually on the Twitter like all
those crazy young kids are and if I'm
gonna do an in-store appearance or I
post something on my website I tweet
these followers a word I don't like so
much and over 50,000 people go like okay
I got it what they do with it I I don't
have any idea but I love that idea
if I can get to you and you can get get
to me very quickly but it's also allowed
media to become convincingly transparent
while they become mischievously and
maliciously non transparent and in the
media the now what you get now is loss
of opportunity to to get information and
loss of opportunity for the information
to be
misinformation disinformation
non-information distractive information
when we should be looking at this we're
gonna find out about the Kardashians
because we can point and click and so I
blame CNN as much as I blame the Bush
administration for all the dead
Americans and the dead Iraqis in Iraq
I think CNN was complicit I think all
the news outlets I think they knew more
than that what they were saying I think
they were afraid of losing access to the
president to the White House to this
skinny by not reporting all that they
knew so eventually they are moral
cowards at best at worse they are war
criminals they are co-conspirators in a
mass murder and maybe they should need
to be eating government cheese
sandwiches and wearing bright orange
suits Dick Cheney George W Bush Donald
Rumsfeld certainly need to go to a court
of law and ask and answer some very very
straight-ahead questions with all
truthfulness so do people at CNN Fox
News CNBC MSNBC The New York Times The
Washington Post and on and on and on
because they knew more than what they
told because they're sucking up to a
corporate bottom line and they wanted
access so they traded the truth for
access and basically we got non
transparency on everything from 9/11 to
the invasion and occupation of Iraq to
what's going on with drone strikes in
Pakistan to wherever else you are not
getting and I'm not mr. conspiracy
theory boy that you are not getting
total transparency in the media is kind
of a no-brainer and I don't think
anyone's really gonna argue that unless
they own CNN or Fox News and they'll
just you know they'll tell you what
they're gonna tell you but as a consumer
I'm not I in Stein but I do know when
I'm getting pulled around and I think
we're getting pulled around quite a bit
that lack of bravery and that lack of
transparency in the media has gotten a
lot of people killed it made a lot of
people go broke and it's moral cowardice
that is the most despicable part about
this I wonder how : Paulo sleeps at
night I'd like to have a word with him
because he lied he lied he lied to me he
lied to my face through the camera at
the UN